استعاده خير سون من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
في تطور لافط في سير المعارك ينظف ينضم
الينا الان من كيف يوري ساك مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني رئيس زيلانكي السيد اهلا
وسهلا بك همم اعتبر هذا اليوم تاريخي
لماذا
مدينه اوكرانيه مهمه
مركز الاقليميه الوحيد الذي تمكن الروس
المعتدين من السيطره عليه بشكل مؤقت الان
نحن بدخولنا الى اخر السنه نحن نثبت
للعالم مره اخرى باننا هزمنا رؤوس فيك يا
ابو شرنيف وفي خريف الان نحن ندفعهم خارج
خرسان بالتالي هذه تاتي اهميه هذا اليوم
ايضا هنالك رساله لان شعب خرسانه هم كانوا
ينتظرون هذا اليوم لمده طويله هم لم
يرحبوا بالمعتدين الروسي كانوا يحتجون
ضد المعتدين الرؤوس منذ اليوم الاول منذ
اليوم الاول الاحتلال واليوم اخيرا هم
رحبوا بالقوات الاخرانيه في مدينت هو
الحياه ستبدا بالعوده الى طبيعتها هناك
همم ضيفنا الروسي قبل قليل اشار الى ان
خروج القوات الروسيه يعود الى موضوع
الامداد وموضوع الخوف على همم السد
وبالتالي العوده ستكون في الشتاء هل
تتوقعون عوده روسيه الى نفس المنطقه
حسب خطاتهم وهذا امر لا يتعلق بواقع ارض
المعركه لكنه كذلك في خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه تمكن الجيش الروسي من تدمير سلاسل
الامدادات وخطوط الامدادات للجيش الروسي
الجيش الاوكراني وباقتاله القويه اثبت ان
الجيش الروسي لم يتمكن لا يتمكن من البقاء
في خرسان بالتالي هم انسحب
الزائف الاوكرانيين يحاولون ان يفجروا
الساده انا امله ان هؤلاء الروس المعتدين
الارهابيين لا يقومون بعمل غبي لانهم
قاموا بعمليه استفزازيه في الماضي
وبالتاكيد فان وزير الدفاع قال سابقا ان
ده ما كان الروس بالتحلب الغابات الكافي
لتفجير سدي خرسان هم لم يقوم بعمل جيد
لانه لما نظرت الى الخريطه فان جيء الجزء
الايمن من النهر مستواه عالي وسيفيض في
حيث يتمركز القوات الروسيه لكن كم اريد ان
اؤكد ان القوات الروسيه لم تكن لديها خطا
لتفجير
الساده نحن نحارب ونناظر من اجل ارضنا ولا
نقوم بتدمير ارضنا وماذا عن الجرين من
الذي قام
بالاضرار بهما بهذا الشكل
قدامك
الذي رايناه اليوم كان حسب فهميت قام حدث
بسبب انسحاب القوات الروسيه لانه كان تشعر
بالخوف من انها سنلحق بهم وسنقوم بذلك
عاجلا ام اجل ان هذا فقط
لمحاولتي فصلي الجزء الاخر من النهار هم
قاموا بتدمير هذه الجسور لكن الجيش
الاخراني كان يستهدف هذه الصور في الماضي
ليس هذه الجذور تحديدا لكن توجب علينا ان
نعيق طرق امداداتهم وتجهيزاتهم نجعل من
المستحيل على المعتدين ان يظلوا في خرسان
لذلك قبل ان نتضر بهذه الجسور
لكن ضرار كان جزئيا لكن الضرر الذي احدثه
كان ضرر ضرار
وحشيا ولا يمكن المقارنه بين الاثنين
تعالوا كلاني منكياف